필사람 중개법인의 빌딩 투벅이
도산대로 빌딩 시 조한 팀장입니다.
오늘 저희가 이렇게 모인 이유는 코마
빌딩 스터디를 진행을 합니다. 박수
한번
치고요. 꼬빌스라고 이제 줄여서
부르는데 어 꼬빌스가 뭐냐면은
건물이라는게 똑같은게 하나도
없잖아요. 그래서 여러 건물들을 보고
장단점들을 비교해 보는 과정 속에서이
건물이면 되겠다 안 되겠다라는 거를
좀 많이 어드바이스를 해 주셨어요.
그래서 그 부분 때문에 법무을 구입할
수 있었던 큰 계기가 되지 않았나?
그게 가장 큰 장점이지 않았나? 요런
생각이
듭니다. 기본적으로 수강을 맞췄을
때는요. 여러 가지 이론적인 부분부터
재무적인 부분 실제로 임장까지 나가서
여러 부분들을 다 보여 주셨기 때문에
그런 좀 자신감이 좀 생겼던 거
같아요. 자금을 준비하는 과정까지도
어드바이스를 해 주셔 가지고 매입한
다음에 명도도 하고이 건물을 다시
임대를 맞춰야 되잖아요. 그런
부분들까지도 꼼꼼하게 알려 주셨기
때문에 아주 많이 도움되고 네.
실질적으로 저도 많이 활용도 한 그런
사례입니다. 장사하시는 분들한테 많이
추천을 드리고 싶고요. 그리고 제
케이스가 실질적으로 저는 이제 법인
대출을 이용해서 거의 3억 정도로
22억짜리 건물을 산 케이스기 때문에
소액으로도 건물을 매입할 수 있었기
때문에 큰 금액이 아니더라도이
건물까지 매입하겠다 이런 욕심이
있으신 분들은 저는이 강의 너무너무
추천드립니다. 코마빌딩 스터디 강의를
들으러 오신 분들에게 정말 좀 좋은
건물들을 최근까지도 좀 많이 사
드렸다고 좀 기억을 하는데요. 그중에
가장 많이 말씀하셨던 부분들이 저희
중계사들과 이제 4주간 함께 임장을
돈게 가장 좋았다. 어쨌든 물건을
투자하기에 앞서서 뭐 개별
분석이라든지 비교 평가가 좀
가능했으면 좋겠는데 이제 즉각적으로
좀 질문을 할 수 있고 자주간 같이
임장을 도는 부분에 있어서 최득하기가
정말 좀 수월했다라는 답변들이 굉장히
많았습니다. 이제 한 달 동안 강의를
듣는데 정말 빠르신 분들은 추
안에서도 건물을 매입을 하시는 분들도
계시고요. 평균적으로 매입을 하시는
분들이 보통 다 추강을 듣고 매입을
하셨던 걸로 기억을 합니다. 좋은
건물들 많이 매입을 하셨고요. 어,
그리고 방금 말씀하셨던 거 중에 그
인장이라고 하셨는데 그거는 어떻게 좀
진행이 되는 걸까요? 그 최근에 이제
핫한 지역들, 거래가 많이 되는
지역들, 뭐 인기 있는 지역들을
회의를 통해서 정말 엄선을 합니다.
그래서 그 엄선한 지역들을 토대로
저희가 4주차 이제 거래 사례별로 좀
브리핑을 해 드리고 있습니다. 꼬마
빌딩 시장이 되게 좀 뭐 위기다라고
하는게 있는데 꼬마 빌딩을 좀 어떻게
저희가 좀 접근을 하면 좋을지 한번
여쭤봅니다. 실제로 시장 분위기가
예전과 좀 다른 건 사실이고요.
매수세수세스에도 좀 위축돼 있고
임장을 다녀보면서 실제로 시장인데
그렇게 막 죽은 거는 아닌 거
같다라는 느낌을 좀 많이 받았거든요.
그래서 30억이 저희 꼬수로 좀
진행하면서 느낀게 이제 수간생들이
그냥 강의만 듣는게 아니라 같이 이제
임장을 다니면서 임대 수익이나 개발
가능성까지 스스로 판단을 하면서 눈이
좀 트였다라고 저한테 표현해 주시는
그런 부분들이 너무 좋았습니다.
그래서 앞으로도 이런 시장이 좀
지속될 것으로 보여지는데 어
지금처럼이 불확실한 시기에 공부가 좀
더 제대로 돼야 되고 그다음에 현장을
좀 체험해 보는게 계속적으로 좀
중요해지지 않을까 음라고 좀 느끼고
있습니다. 제가 생각했을 때도 쉽게
얘기해서 매수자의 시장에 사야
된다라고 생각을 합니다. 그래야
물건도 골라서 살 수 있고 내가 편한
마음에 대접을 받으면서 살 수가
있는데요. 보통 놓치시는게 매수자
우위 시장에서의 관심이 제일 적어요.
그러다 보니까 매수자 우위 시장이
오는 거 같고요. 그래서 매수자분들은
이런 타이밍에 압축적으로 공부를 해서
건물 검토를 좀 더 편안하게 하시는게
좋지 않을까 싶습니다. 제가 조금 더
덧붙여서 좀 질문을 드리고 싶은데
지금 뭐 매수자 우의 시장이라고
하셨거든요. 그러면은 투자하기가 좀
적절한 시기인 건지 아닌지에 대해서
좀 여쭤보고 싶습니다네. 방금
말씀드렸다시피 이런 시장에 좀
골라사기가 쉽지 않을까 싶어요. 물론
정말 좋은 입지들은 시장에 나오면은
거래가 또 붙는데요. 그런 물건들도
지금 시장에선 편하게 조금 골라볼 수
있는 시장이지 않을까? 그게 매수자
우의 시장의 좀 장점이지 않을까
싶습니다. 그러면은 지금 매수자 우의
시장이라고 말씀하신 거면은 그
코마피팅 스터디를 통해서 조금 더
이제 폭넓은 실제 매물까지도 좀
받아볼 수가 있는 걸까요? 어, 네.
그러면 그 임장을 도시면서 보통
실거래들 위주로 보다 보니까 많이들
말씀 주시는게 어 내가 조금 더 빨리
좀 물건 검토를 할 수 있을까요?
하면은 저희 그 담당 팀장님들이
물건까지도 좀 소개를 드립니다.
그렇게 하다 보니까 이제 강의를
들으시면서 이제 매입을 하시는
경우들도 많이 발생을 하고요. 수강
중에 계약을 하신 분이 있는 걸로
알고 있는데 네네. 맞습니다. 며칠
만에 결정을 하신 건가요? 제 기억에
정말 빠르신 분이 1주차 2주차 강의
듣고 매입하셨어요. 네. 2주차
1주차 강의 들으시고 이제 물건
검토를 하고 싶으시다고 좀 먼저 좀
연락을 주셨고 그때부터 검토를 했고
본인의 가치 판단이 좀 명확하셨기
때문에 그 물건들 위주로 좀 또 금방
찾아내서 2, 3주 내외로 좀 매입을
했었던 경험이 있습니다. 그래서 혹시
그 물건이 좀 가격이 올랐습니까?
네. 올랐고요. 저렴한 금액에 매입을
했기 때문에 뭐 그렇게 좀 말씀드릴
수 있을 것 같습니다. 그러면은 저희
그 빌산함 호마빌딩 스터디의
장점이라면은 어떤게 있을까요? 뭐
사업하시는 분들, 어떤 뭐 업무를
보시는 분들끼리 또 모임이 형성이
됩니다. 강의가 끝나더라도 지속해서
뭔가 소통을 하시는 분들도 굉장히
많이 봤거든요. 이제 건물 관심이
있으신 분들끼리 뭔가 또 모임을
형성할 수 있다는게 일단은 첫 번째
장점이지 않을까 싶고요. 뭐 수각료도
조금 궁금해하실 거 같아요. 뭐
거기에 좀 이제 꼬마 빌딩 스터디가
어 메리트가 있는지 없는지 타부동산이
진행하는 그런 강의의 수강료를 저희가
공교적으로 밝힐 수는 없지만 저희
회사가 좀 저렴한 편으로 좀 알고
있고요. 그 저희 꼬비스를 통해서
매매까지 이루어진다면 그 수각료는
환급이 되는 그런 장점이 있습니다.
네. 그래서 오늘 뭐 이렇게 재밌게
얘기를 했고요. 다가오는 꼬마빌딩
스터디 36기. 어, 많은 관심요.
저희가 꼬마 빌딩 뭐 임장 스터디는
최초라는 점 기억해 주시면은 감사할
것 같고 이만 인사드리겠습니다.